the saints properly at number five on
the preseason power rankings we continue
to work our way up that stack all the
way to number one as we preview a team's
season now the saints have knocked on
the door for three straight years and
the saints are kind of like
the buffalo bills of the early 90s even
though the bills made it to the super
bowl and that's where they had their
losses and went back to zero and zero
and did it again you could argue what
the saints are doing is even more
impressive because
they just aren't losing a super bowl by
30 points now the bill's first one was
one they they could have should have won
but but the saints are having their
hearts ripped out and and and their
hearts are being stomped on and it's a
different way every time
that they have this traumatic loss in
the playoffs and they find a way to
reset and come back and be every bit as
good as they were and be one of the best
teams in the conference and there's no
reason to think they're not going to do
it again this year chris no there's not
any reason for me at least i know that i
know you i mean obviously you're a
believer too well first thing is sean
payton i mean sean payton's one of the
best coaches in the nfl there's no
arguing that he's an unbelievable
offensive mind his teams we always think
about them as oh wow they put off all
these passing yards and all that
gosh the second thing i think of
after offensive genius is physicality
when i think of sean payton i mean all
these big dudes they got on the
offensive line and defensive line and
they fly around and throw their bodies
around with you know no regard to their
body and i think that speaks to sean
payton the kind of guys he gets and he's
got a little bit of that renegade
attitude himself to where you know it's
a feeding frenzy for that team so i love
watching them play football and they're
talented as hell we know that yeah i
expect them to be there and
the way they bounce back and some of
these losses is just it is it's
heartbreaking it's a testament to peyton
drew brees and some of the other leaders
they got on the team but really when you
look at them hey the first thing that
just jumps out to me mike always with
some of these really good teams offense
and defensive line there's just no team
in football that they're going to lose a
match up to as far as the in the
trenches they might have a few
stalemates but man it's one of the
better offensive lines in football it's
one of the better defensive lines in
football and if they can get a guy like
marcus davenport to show up to the party
after they traded those assets further
you know in a first round pick and get
him to become something off the edge and
a threat that way watch out for this
saints defense
you know in a weird sort of way i feel
like the fact that the saints won a
super bowl 11 years ago with payton as
the coach and brees is the quarterback
makes it easier for them to deal with
this disappointment if they were chasing
their first ring still right and they
were getting that close and being thrown
back into you know the the valley of
zero and zero and have to do it all
again i i think the pressure might get
to them they would break at some point
right right the fact that they have that
ring allows them to keep going and keep
going and eventually there's going to be
enough new guys
and there probably already are who don't
have that ring it's going to be hard to
hold it together but it's amazing what
the saints have been able to do going
back every year starting again being
dominant and having the rug pulled out
from under them before they could get
back to the super bowl all right a
little what's more likely new orleans
saints edition what's more likely alvin
camaro rushes for a thousand yards or
latavius murray has more touchdowns than
camara camaro's career high is 883
rushing yards and last year murray and
camara each had six rushing touchdowns
so what's more likely i'm gonna go with
the alvin kamara without i'm in a
thousand yards i i just have a i just
think this is a year he's gonna go off i
do now the contract situation might be a
little bit of a factor in that right
there i would probably feel more comf
confident right in in camara if if he
gets this new deal to go okay he's going
to lay it on the line and now that they
know they have them signed up they're
going to use them right like they're not
going to like okay we've signed you up
we've given this money we're going to
get our money's worth out of you too so
i guess there's a little bit of a
trepidation from that aspect for me but
regardless i think this is a year where
camara is
really gonna go off in this offense
yeah and look that's uh part of the
analysis and part of the risk if you pay
the guy a lot of
money does he does he still have that
drive
that you know for running backs and
defensive tackles to me those are the
guys where sometimes when they get paid
a ton of money they lose that extra
little edge that they have when they're
chasing the bag sure once they get it
they maybe lose a little bit of it we'll
see if that happens to christian
mccaffrey this year now that he's cashed
in as well but yeah you know now you're
chasing legacies once you get the money
you're chasing legacies but uh we'll
we'll see i mean i don't i think between
the two camara is more likely to get to
a thousand yards but but i think it's
telling that he hasn't gotten there yet
they like to use multiple running backs
that's the way they've always been under
sean payton you're right they have i
mean you know mark ingram being there
before that and all that as well now you
know camara has an ability to be a home
run hitter too i mean not that he's
gonna go 80 and 90 yards but you know
he's got an ability to break a few
tackles and 40 and 50 yard touchdown
runs and do that type of uh thing as
well but he he
is just unbelievable you know
versatility and that's where he's got
great importance to that offense um so
yeah i do i think it's going to be a big
year for him and i think he's mike just
the last thing with this is i just think
he's one of those guys that he loves
football he always has you give him the
money he's gonna thrive you don't give
them the money he's too smart he's too
talented he's gonna take gas off you
know take his foot off the gas pedal
just a little because he's going to be
worried about protecting himself and
making sure he's healthy to get into
free agency next year
all right next what's more likely drew
brees gets an mvp vote or taysom hill
attempts 25 passes hill has 15 career
passes including the postseason man
i don't think i can get i i mean i'm
going to say drew brees just an mvp vote
because i just i can't imagine taysom
hill throwing more than 25 passes in a
given year i don't know he might have
half a game yeah one and a half a game
and they're working him toward being the
quarterback next year don't you think
they should give him a little more i do
for opportunity i do i i mean i i would
that's nice but it's just easier said
than done you know what i mean to where
i think there's certain weeks where okay
some of those plays don't fit into the
way the game's going hey we're kind of
dominating why show us you know why show
this special taste some hill play we
have or hey drew's hit 24 to the last 28
why the hell do i want to mess up that
rhythm you know i just feel like that'll
come into play in a week here and there
but you know i know they're going to put
them on the field and do their best uh
but yeah i guess i'll i'll do the mvp
vote for drew there which one you're
going to do
i'm going more than 25 passes why okay
they paid taysom hill a two-year
well that what is it it's a it's a
two-year deal yes that pays out a total
of 16 16 million guaranteed at signing
uh you don't pay 16 million guaranteed
signing if you don't plan to use the guy
and i think we're going to see him
whether it's throwing deep passes
whether he's going to be a change of
pace whatever the case may be i think
we're going to see more taste in hell
remember drew brees told us the super
bowl he's fine with however many now
anybody can say that but he said it he's
on the record he's fine if taysom hill
comes in and plays some this year i
don't disagree with you that we'll see
more of them i just don't know if i can
like buy into it'll be 25 passes that's
that that's where i guess i'm just
worried but i agree with you if that
they're going to get their money's worth
out of the guy and he's going to get
carries and be that guy go ahead quickly
win the super bowl win the super bowl
the saints of course can win the super
bowl there's no doubt about it there's
really not a weakness to their football
team
okay i agree worst case worst case
worst case is like i look at they're
like the seventh seed i don't i just
think it's a playoff team when i look at
it you know i just don't find a lot of
weaknesses like i said maybe the
secondary cover guys okay there's just
it's nitpicky there's just the issues i
have with their roster are my newt to me
well so like i said yesterday with the
bucks worst cases they get in at least
as the seven seed so we're both
basically in agreement that the bucks
and the saints are getting in so why
even bother to play i'm not a totally
agreement with the bucks with you all
there all the way so you feel more
strongly about the saints and the bucks
i do get again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports